a leader at the height of her power here
Nicholas sturgeon cleaning up in the
2019 general election
wild dominant in Scottish politics too
as the longest serving first minister of
Scotland
the fast woman to lead the country
and the first whose departure from high
office has not involved death defeat or
scandal
Korea span into
punctuated with great highs
but also lows leaving office her Mission
unfulfilled
Nicholas Sergeant was born in 1970 in
airshare this part of West Scotland a
labor Heartland but with Margaret
Thatcher in power it was the SMP she
joined at the age of 16. in the late
1980s as Alex salmond attempted to make
his mark on Westminster Nicholas
sturgeon was in Glasgow studying law
debating and campaigning quiet serious
and focused she's soon impressed within
the SMP later becoming her party's
Deputy leader and then Deputy first
minister to Mr salmond the man she
described as her mentor
she soon formalized another relationship
marrying Peter Morrell the snp's
longtime chief executive
[Applause]
a year later and an SMP majority at
Hollywood in 2011 meant a mandate for an
independence referendum and a huge
opportunity for Nicholas sturgeon
after the pro-independence campaign lost
the 2014 vote and Alex salmond resigned
the dream shall never die
it was that dream that Nicholas Sargent
inherited succeed in him as Scotland's
fast female Premiere a modern and
confident Scotland fit for purpose and
fit for all of her people and out of
Salmon's Shadow starge and Sean the 2015
election her breakout moment it simply
cannot be and it will not be business as
usual when it comes to westminster's
dealing with Scotland
the SMP almost wiped out Scottish labor
and have been the third party at
Westminster ever since will a change of
leadership shift that landscape to I'm
not completing Libra has to set out new
ideas New Vision and a new passion for
how we build a more prosperous future
for Scotland and it is a significant
moment a significant opportunity but
that means I was setting out what that
positive change looks like and I relish
the opportunity to do that a strong
performer Nicholas sturgeon impressed in
the 2015 TV debates a master of the
selfie II all helping to build an image
of a modern political leader but when it
came to policy her record much more
mixed there's no doubt that she was
successful at The Ballot Box but in
terms of using that power and there were
there were key feelings one of them was
the education attainment gap which she
said she would close she made that
promise that never happened Scotland has
got a shameful drugs death record that
barely shifted as well and look at
kiosks in the hill service from the GP
service through the a e and also in the
ambulances there's no doubt that
Nicholas surgeon's domestic record is
very patchy Scottish Parliament as she
continued at The Ballot Box UK prime
ministers came and went
Nicholas sturgeon of Thorne in the side
of successive PMS a less prickly
relationship with her latest counterpart
but their political objectives miles
apart let me first start by paying
tribute to Nicholas sturgeon for her
long-standing public service and I wish
her well in the future I've consistently
said that I think what people in
Scotland want to see is their two
governments the Scottish government and
the UK government working constructively
together on the priorities that really
matter to people
brexit another fault line between
hollyrood and Westminster opposed by the
majority of Scots it reignited the
question of Scottish independence again
but failed to get Nicholas sturgeon much
closer to an independence vote the
Supreme Court ruling last year that
hollyrood does not have the power to
legislate for a referendum on Scottish
independence
holyrood overruled two over the rights
for transgender people as the government
in Westminster blocked a quality
legislation over the fears for the
impact on safe spaces for females but
Nicholas sturgeon's potent combination
of communication and political skills
proved invaluable during the pandemic
she was widely praised for her
leadership even though mistakes were
made and many thousands died
but soon after came perhaps her lowest
moment when the Scottish government's
botched mishandling of harassment
complaints against Alex salmond and Miss
sturgeon's role since turned a
friendship into a bitter Feud I will
tell the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth by choosing the
timing of her departure Nicholas
Sergeant Remains the master of her own
destiny but she leaves office having
failed to determine Scotland's that
second referendum further away and a
vacuum at the top of her party
Scotland's political land shape has
shifted and not necessarily to the smp's
advantage